في الخطوط الأمامية في بياناتها ، كل
شبر من الأراضي المكتسبة أو المفقودة
قد خاضت قتالًا وحشيًا بسبب شل
اليمن وتدمير شعبه حيث
يعمل العالم أخيرًا على إجبار
التحالف الذي تقوده السعودية المدعوم من الولايات
المتحدة والمتمردين الحوثيين المدعومين من إيران على
اتفاق من أجل ذلك.  كثير من الشعر ، لقد فات الأوان بالفعل ،
ما نحن على وشك أن نظهره لك
يكاد لا يمكن تصوره في رعبه ،
هذه نداءات عمرها تسعة أشهر ،
تم تصويرها مؤخرًا داخل عيادة محلية ،
توفي خليل بينما كان الفريق الطبي
يكافح لإحيائه ، حيث اقترض والده اليائس
المال  لإحضاره إلى هنا ،
ويا غادر معه جسم صغير مل
وف باللون الأبيض في المستشفيات وا
عيادات في جميع أنحاء اليمن الوقت ينفد ال
غير نسيم الذي يكبره بتسعة أشهر أيضًا وه
يكافح حتى يبقي عينيه مفتوحتين ، وي
ضاءل الدعم للحرب في ال
من  يرغب العديد من المشرعين الأمريكيين في الخروج ، على الرغم من أن
وزير الخارجية الأمريكي مايك بومبيو قال إنه
بدون مشاركة أمريكية ستكون الحياة هنا
أسوأ ، من الصعب رؤية مدى قرب
ميل فالي سي إن إن